hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well near the end of his conclusion to
part three of his proma to any future
metaphysics KH is going to come back to
the the
exploration of boundaries or bounds or
if you like limits although we want to
be a little bit careful in using that
term the German is grenen Right which we
in some context we'll translate as
limits but here we're usually
translating as boundaries or bounds and
he is going to say at the beginning of
this note this conclusion I made use of
the
metaphor a Zin build literally a thing
that you could
sensuously picture or grasp of a
boundary GZA to establish limits shanken
of Reason in regard to its suitable use
now when he did that there's really two
things that we want to point out so one
of these is that he actually did make a
distinction between uh boundaries and uh
limits right so this is uh important he
says bounds in extended things always
presuppose a space existing outside a
definite place and enclosing it limits
Gren do not require this but are mere
negations which affect a quantity in so
far as it is not absolutely complete and
reason has both limits and Bounds or
boundaries right so that that's an
important thing to keep in mind and then
he uses a spatial metaphor we almost
can't avoid spatial metaphors with
respect to this and he's going to talk
about an empty space right um the
contrast between the occupied space
which we can have knowledge of versus
the void or
right so that's also quite important now
coming back to section 59 he continues
and he says the world of sense contains
merely appearances Shin which are not
things in themselves but the
understanding must assume these latter
ones that is Numa because it knows the
objects of experience to be mere
appearances so he's going to then say
in our reason both are comprised
together so what are what are both
comprised together well the Numa the
things of themselves which we can't know
but we also can't avoid thinking about
and all of the appearances which are
connected in a cohesive systematic rule
bound world that we experience so reason
is grasping both of these and then he
says and the question def Fraga
is is what how does reason set
boundaries to the understanding as
regards to both Fields the field of
experience and sense the other field of
the
unknowable
Numa how does reason do this and now
notice what he's saying here reason
isn't just finding limits how does
reason itself actively
impose limits penen is the verb that
Kant is using there to place limits and
it is placing limits both for the
understanding and for
itself so we're confronted with some
interesting insights here by KT so he's
going to start out not by saying how
reason actually imposes these limits
itself but what reason
realizes by looking
at other things so
experience which contains all that
belongs to the sensible world does not
bound itself
right so it doesn't manage to restrict
to impose limits upon itself it can it
can uh impose limits in the sense of
shanken right but it can't impose
boundaries on itself why not well
because it proceeds in every case from
the condition to some other equally
conditioned thing so its boundary must
lie quite without it okay so what is
that boundary then well it's in these
pure beings of the understanding the
field of them but this field he says as
far as the determination of the nature
of those beings is concerned so figuring
out exactly what they are having
knowledge about them we don't have that
so the pure beings of the understanding
he says is an empty space a real for us
and if dogmatically determined concepts
are being considered we cannot pass
beyond the field of possible experience
so if we're too restrictive to demanding
in what we want out of these things in
themselves well we can't get to them at
all we can't have knowledge of them so K
is going to go on further and now we're
moving from the negative to the positive
he says that a
boundary is itself something positive
how is a boundary positive it's
restrictive isn't it saying you can't go
any further it's negating well it's
positive in the sense that it's setting
something in place in space we might say
mental space so he tells us that the
boundary is positive because it belongs
to two different things two different
sets of things what lies within it okay
so great the boundary contains some
things but it also belongs to what is
without what is past the boundary right
so he tells us um
it is still an active positive cognition
now this is an important term here eress
eress can be translated as cognition it
can also be translated as knowledge so
we can't actually have knowledge of what
the things in themselves
are the numina but we can have knowledge
Arness of this
boundary so
that's an important advance and I don't
want you to not see that it's not just
something we can think it's something we
can actually know so how is that
possible he says that uh it's an active
positive cognition which reason only
acquires by now we could say
enlarging um or by extending would also
be a good translation irite it a reason
why Wiens itself extends itself to this
boundary without attempting to pass it
why now the translation can be a little
bit misleading it finds itself in the
presence of an empty space now there
that sounds a little bit oxymoronic
doesn't it presence you know filling
empty space so it just says it actually
finds itself finds empty space uh before
it so um and then it thinks
within that empty
space something it doesn't know the
something that it's thinking but it says
it can think the forms
deforming of things dinging but not the
things
themselves so what are these these
forms they're not fully determined right
but that doesn't mean that we can't
think whatever's past that boundary
whatever is moving from the phenomenal
to the Nal we just can't fully
comprehend it we can't apply the same
sort of Concepts that we have over in
the realm of experience to the things in
themselves which are Beyond this
boundary right so he goes on and he says
that um the setting of a boundary to the
field of experience by something which
is is otherwise unknown to reason is
still a cognition which belongs to it
belongs to reason even at this point and
by which it is neither confined within
the sensible reason is not confined just
in the sensible nor Strays beyond the
sensible but limits
itself reason imposes its own limits on
itself as befits the knowledge of a
boundary and what does it do limits
itself to the relation
between what lies Beyond it and what is
contained within it so we really could
say we have you know several different
moving Parts here we have what is within
what is without experience the ninal
things in themselves the boundary and
then we have reason reason has extended
itself up to this point thinks the
things that are on the other side of
that boundary thinks the boundary itself
and thinks the
relation between
what is on each side of the boundary now
Kant actually provides us here with an
example that we can use which he's
already developed a bit earlier in this
talking about natural theology what is
natural theology trying to determine
something about what it is that we call
God the Divine using just the resources
of reason and potentially experience not
Revelation so he natural theology is
such a concept at the boundary of human
reason being constrained to look Beyond
this boundary to the idea notice that he
doesn't say the reality notice that he
doesn't say the determination the idea
of a Supreme Being and for practical
purposes to that of an intelligible
World
also not in order to determine anything
relatively to this mere being of the
understanding which lies beyond the
world of sense but to guide the use of
Reason within the world of sense
according to principles of the greatest
possible Unity so reason makes use of
the reference of the world of sense to
an independent reason so it looks at the
world of sense goes beyond the boundary
that's that's a a reference here as the
cause of all the world's connections
reason does not merely invent a being
but as beyond the sensible World there
must be something that can be thought
only by the pure understanding reason
determined this something in this
particular way something that's on the
other side of the boundary though only
of course according to analogy which
he's discussed earlier in this section
where he was distinguishing between
theism and theism and the use of analogy
in both of these so what we have here is
reason recognizing and imposing this
boundary between the world of experience
the phenomenal and the ideas of the
understanding ideas of Reason which are
ninal ultimately and there's this
important boundary and reason is what
can confine itself to these and look at
the relation between these two Fields so
this is a fuller development of the
boundaries of reason now it's no longer
something reason bumps into it's
something that reason
recognizes and can impose upon
itself